[Música]
hola me llamo giovanna gaitán soy
psicóloga y mi plática se llama diseña
tu vida y a través de vivirla el día que
cumplí treinta años entré en crisis si
la famosa crisis de los treinta se
apoderó de mí pensó en mi proyecto de
vida ese que hacemos cuando estamos en
prepa o en la universidad y en donde nos
planteamos mil objetivos que queremos
lograr en nuestra vida y al que le
ponemos plazos y según mi proyecto para
esa edad yo ya debía estar casada tener
hijos un súper trabajo una maestría
haber viajado en mil cosas más que me
había propuesto para cuando cumpliera 30
por eso cuando el plazo se cumplió me
deprimí resulta que no estaba casada
mucho menos tenía hijos y lo peor es que
no estaban ni cerca de lograrlo sentí
que había fracasado que no tenía un
propósito que no había logrado las metas
más importantes de mi vida y me
preguntaba por qué que hice mal después
de unos días de sentirme completamente
perdida
la psicóloga en mí dijo basta giovanna
me puse auto analizar me voy a
reflexionar sobre mi vida y me di cuenta
que aunque estaba casada ni tenía hijos
si había logrado otras cosas que eran
muy importantes para mí tenía una
carrera y un trabajo que me encantan una
maestría había viajado me había echado
de un paracaídas era independiente y
muchas cosas más que daban un sentido a
mi vida cuando me di cuenta de eso me
sentí tranquila por un tiempo me di
chance a mí misma de disfrutar mi vida
de esa nueva etapa y de posponer un poco
algunos de mis planes sin embargo seguía
en esa lucha interna
me sentía presionada porque esa meta no
cumplida de casarme y tener hijos se
convirtió en una obsesión y opacaba a
mis demás objetivos me aferré a esa idea
no sólo porque era algo que yo misma me
había planteado algo que pensaba que
quería sino porque los demás también
esperaban eso de mí desde niña me había
visualizado con un esposo hijo
gemelos además una casa grande
trabajando y lo convertí en un ideal de
vida además la sociedad me decía que era
algo que debía de hacer para ser feliz
para sentirme una mujer plena completa y
para sentir que mi vida tenía un
propósito y un sentido
conforme pasaban los años esas
expectativas y esa presión social
pesaban cada vez más en reuniones
familiares o con amigos me decían cosas
como si tú para cuando yo vi el reloj
biológico la edad vas a ser abuela en
vez de mamá mis amigas y mis primas se
casaban y yo no empecé a presionarme y a
sentir que tenía que cumplir con esas
expectativas de todo el mundo llegó un
punto en el que pensé bueno si a los 35
no me he casado pues al menos tengo un
hijo o adopto y se convirtió en mi plan
b era como una forma de decirme a mí
misma tranquila giovanna si lo vas a
lograr como sea pero lo vas a lograr sin
embargo conforme pasaba el tiempo y se
acercaban los 35 me empecé a preguntar
si de verdad era algo que necesitaba o
deseaba para ser feliz
me empecé a cuestionar si esas metas
realmente eran mías o si me estaba
dejando llevar por la presión social y
las expectativas ajenas y así como yo
quisiera que ustedes también se tomaran
un momento para pensar en su proyecto en
esa lista de cosas que se han propuesto
realizar en su vida y que piensen cómo
van y que se cuestionen
cuántas de esas metas realmente son
suyas o son de su familia de sus amigos
de su pareja a compañeros de la sociedad
en la que viven cuántos de esos sueños
que están persiguiendo de verdad son
suyos si los están persiguiendo por
convicción o por qué es lo que se supone
que deben de hacer y yo me pregunto
donde dice o quien dijo que la vida debe
de llevar una secuencia específica que
sea igual para todos quien dice que
debemos de hacer las cosas en un orden o
de una manera determinada porque solo
así vamos a tener éxito oa sentirnos
plenos y felices quien dice cuando yo me
planté todas estas preguntas y empecé a
cuestionar esa obsesión que tenía y esas
ideas acerca de la felicidad y lo que
daba sentido a mi vida me pregunté de
verdad es lo que quiero y me di cuenta
que cada vez me agradaba menos la idea
de ser mamá
ahora el hecho de casarme y tener hijos
en vez de generar mi ilusión y emoción
me causaban conflicto porque no quería
cambiar mi estilo de vida me gustaba
cada vez más mi libertad mi
independencia mi trabajo el poder salir
viajar o hacer lo que yo quisiera sin
tener que rendir cuentas a nadie o sin
tener esa responsabilidad y me agradaba
cada vez más mi vida recuerdo que en una
ocasión platicando con una alumna me
dijo yo admiro mucho tu vida algún día
quiero ser como tú y escuchar eso me
sorprendió que alguien de 20 años
quisiera ser como yo me cambió la
perspectiva y me puso a pensar más me
pregunté qué quiero realmente para mí de
este proyecto de vida aquí se hace
tantos años que me estás aún son válidas
cuantas aún me interesan de esos sueños
que tenía cuando era más joven cuántos
aún los tengo en el presente
y la respuesta fue que yo ya no era la
misma que hace 15 o 10 años que ya no
quería las mismas cosas y que estaba
bien
está bien cambiar está bien querer cosas
diferentes y que no porque lo había
plasmado en un papel hace tantos años
tenía que hacerlo como lo había dicho y
quisiera aclarar algo la culpa no es del
proyecto ni se trata de no tener metas
yo como psicóloga trabajo con muchos
jóvenes y los ayudo a hacer el suyo el
problema es que lo convertimos en un
decreto oficial de cómo tiene que ser
nuestra vida y que debemos seguir sin
perder el rumbo sin equivocarnos el
problema es que se vuelve rígido o que
lo hagamos pensando en lo que debe de
ser o en lo que tengo que lograr según
los demás
la sociedad nos impone muchas
expectativas y muchos estereotipos desde
que nacemos niño azul niña rosa pelotas
muñecas y en ocasiones nos la creemos
creemos que debemos de cumplir con
ciertos roles estudiar una carrera
importante tener un trabajo formal
casarnos tener hijos
ser exitosos
sobre salida como de lugar
tanto hombres como mujeres cargamos con
ese peso de los bebés y nos presionamos
pensando que tenemos que lograr ciertas
metas yo lo he visto con muchos
pacientes que viven complaciendo a sus
papás a sus familias a sus parejas y que
se sienten culpables cuando no cumplen
con esas expectativas ajenas
y yo no estoy en contra de tener metas o
de buscar este trabajo exitoso o tener
una familia o estudiar o viajar o lo que
sea que cada quien quiera siempre y
cuando se pregunten si eso de verdad los
hace felices y los hace sentir a gusto
con ustedes mismos he aprendido que
tener un plan de vida es útil porque nos
da una guía de hacia dónde queremos ir
sin embargo pienso que debe de ser
flexible y que debemos revisarlo
constantemente y revisar nos a nosotros
mismos conocernos y preguntarnos qué
quiero para mi vida y replantearnos el
camino cuando sea necesario pero sobre
todo pienso que debemos hacerlo centrado
en nuestros propios ideales no es lo que
los demás esperan de nosotros
responder a ciertas preguntas como que
me gusta que metas tengo cómo me veo a
futuro cuáles son mis habilidades que me
hace feliz puede ayudarlos a tener una
visión más clara de lo que quieren en su
vida además creo que es importante
considerar todas las áreas personal
familiar social profesional porque todas
ellas se complementan y una decisión en
una de ellas afecta a todas las demás
creo que al considerar todos estos
aspectos podrán sentirse más a gusto con
el rumbo que diseñen para sus vidas
hoy a mis 37 años puedo decirles que
aunque no me he casado ni tengo hijos me
siento feliz plena y satisfecha con lo
que he logrado me he reinventado y sigo
planteando me metas tampoco estoy
peleada con la idea de casarme algún día
si pasa bien si no también hoy tengo
otras prioridades y me siento a gusto
con ellas creo que de eso se trata la
vida de diseñarla según nuestros ideales
de atrevernos a decidir el rumbo que
queremos seguir de equivocarnos y
replantearnos el camino
de aventurarnos y dejar el miedo y el
que dirán a un lado de tomar riesgos de
romper estereotipos y dejar de complacer
a todo el mundo para empezar a complacer
nos a nosotros mismos quiero invitarlos
a que sean capaces de tomar sus propias
decisiones de elegir que los hace
felices ya diseñar o rediseñar la vida
que ustedes quieran y que se atrevan a
vivirla día a día que no vivan bajo
expectativas ajenas ni bajo un plan de
vida socialmente diseñado que nos dice
que debemos de seguir ciertos pasos o
ciertas reglas para ser felices
hoy yo vivo mi vida como quiero pongo
mis reglas
sigo diseñando el rumbo que quiero
disfruta mi familia a mis amigos viajar
mi trabajo y hoy soy muy feliz
gracias
[Música]